(En 1991, la segunda mayor potencia militar
del planeta y uno de los ejércitos más poderosos
del mundo se enfrentan a un futuro incierto.
Miles de hombres en edad militar, con formación
de élite y conocimiento avanzado en las terribles
prácticas soviéticas son fichados por empresas
militares y sobreviven como soldados de fortuna.
Si usted tiene algún problema y dinero suficiente,
quizás pueda contratarlos…
El equipo, ¡Rusia!)
Querida comunidad de VisualPolitik, no penséis
ni por un segundo que estamos exagerando.
Actualmente en nuestro mundo hay decenas y
decenas de empresas de fuerzas militares que
operan en conflictos internacionales, sobre
todo en África.
Son las llamadas EMSP, empresas militares
y de seguridad privado. Y no, con lo de fuerzas
de seguridad privada no nos referimos a los
guardias que podemos encontrar en centros
comerciales o en la empresa de alarmas que
tengas contratada.
Hablamos de auténticas organizaciones de
soldados con formación y equipamiento militar
avanzado que son contratadas por dinero.
¿Queréis saber más sobre el desconocido
mundo de los “ejércitos privados”? Pues…
Arranquemos.
[Antes de comenzar, dejadme que os hable de nuestro Patreon. Si ya eres suscriptor de VisualPolitik y te gusta lo que hacemos, ahora
puedes ayudarnos a seguir mejorando día a
día sumándote a nuestra comunidad en Patreon.
Tienes cinco niveles diferentes para elegir,
cada uno de ellos con distintos beneficios
exclusivos. Desde nuestro conocido boletín,
“Las claves de la semana”, a vídeos editoriales
extra o regalos exclusivos para patronos.
Si queréis echarle un vistazo os dejamos
el enlace en la descripción.]
Dicho esto comencemos. Y podemos hacerlo,
si os parece, con una pregunta: ¿Son los
ejércitos privados un fenómeno único de
los países de Europa del Este?
Pues No, desde luego que no. Porque amigos,
aunque el equipo A fue una serie de ciencia
ficción, el concepto subyacente es muy real.
Mucho más de lo que podríamos pensar. Tanto
en el este… como en el oeste. Aunque, por
supuesto, podemos encontrar algunas diferencias.
(En Occidente también hay una importante
industria de Empresas militares y de seguridad
privada, sin embargo, son un tanto diferentes
a las que podemos encontrar, por ejemplo,
en Rusia.
De esta forma, mientras que este tipo de empresas
rusas sí prestan habitualmente servicios
de combate, las occidentales - que son fundamentalmente
estadounidenses - se centran sobre todo en
prestar apoyo militar, proteger infraestructuras
clave - incluidas, por supuesto, las infraestructuras
militares - o encargarse de realizar labores
técnicas avanzadas.
Sin embargo por lo general - lo que no quiere
decir siempre - son reacias a participar en
combates directos)
¡Stop! Un momento, un momento, porque antes
de seguir por esta senda la pregunta que podemos
hacernos llegados hasta aquí:
En VisualPolitik me están hablando de empresas
militares privadas, pero ¿Realmente son este
tipo de compañía aceptadas por la comunidad
internacional?
Pues… Bueno, digamos que aquí tenemos que
hacer muchos matices.
Y es que veréis, en 1989 y tras hacerse públicas
varias atrocidades cometidas por cuerpos de
mercenarios en África, tuvo lugar la Convención
Internacional contra el Reclutamiento, Utilización,
Financiación y Entrenamiento de Mercenarios.
(Esta convención, impulsada por las Naciones
Unidas, buscaba prohibir tanto a los mercenarios
como también las empresas privadas militares,
a las que considera poco más que una evolución
de los primeros.
La idea era que, para finales de 2001, todos
los países evitaran recurrir a mercenarios
y a empresas militares privadas. Sin embargo,
hasta el día de hoy apenas 46 países la
han ratificado. Y, por supuesto, entre los
46 no están quienes más uso hacen de estos
servicios. Ni siquiera un país como España
está en esa reducida lista.)
Y sí, ¡por supuesto! Ni Estados Unidos,
ni Rusia ni el Reino Unido, con mucha diferencia
los tres países que más uso hacen de este
tipo de instrumentos, están en la lista de
firmantes.
En cualquier caso la cuestión es que hablamos
de toda una enorme industria que, a nivel
mundial, mueve entre 20.000 y 100.000 millones
de dólares anuales, y que en ocasiones obtiene
contratos tan importantes como estos:
(En Afganistán, se gastaron “más de 100.000
millones de dólares en contratistas militares”
Un informe de Bloomberg apunta a que, en abril
de 2021, había 16.832 trabajadores empleados
por contratistas militares privados en Afganistán,
siendo 6.147 de ellos ciudadanos estadounidenses.
Eso era más del doble de los 2.500 soldados
estadounidenses que quedaban en ese momento.
Politifact)
Pues sí, puede resultarnos sorprendente pero
recurrir a unidades militares privadas es
mucho más común de lo que podríamos pensar
a simple vista. Empresas fundamentalmente
de Estados Unidos y Rusia que luego a su vez,
en muchas casos, subcontratan o montan empresas
locales en el propio terreno de las operaciones.
Si necesitas un cuerpo de élite para proteger
una instalación, si necesitas un equipo que
se encargue de dar formación militar avanzada,
si necesitas labores de inteligencia, localización
de agentes enemigos, control de radar, gestión
de misiles avanzados, lo que sea, tan solo
tienes que coger el teléfono y pedir presupuesto.
Bueno, no es tan sencillo, pero ya me entendéis.
Ahora bien, ¿Por qué hablamos de Rusia?
¿Cuál es la diferencia, la clave que hace
que la industria militar privada rusa suela
ir mucho más allá que la norteamericana?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todo:
Si tienes que contratar una empresa de este
tipo, ¿Por qué demonios Rusia es una opción
tan popular?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(¿CRUZANDO LA LÍNEA?)
¿Por qué Rusia se ha convertido en todo
un Hub de empresas militares privadas?
Para responder a esta pregunta tenemos que
echar la vista atrás: la caída de la Unión
Soviética dejó a miles y miles y miles de
militares sin trabajo.
(Tras el colapso de la URSS, el ejército
experimentó una importante reducción en
el número de hombres porque había un enorme
excedente. La Unión Soviética había sido
un estado en gran medida militarizado y tras
su caída ni hacían faltan tantas unidades
militares ni había como pagarlas.
Esto hizo que muchos soldados, e incluso también
oficiales y personal de mayor rango, tuvieran
que buscarse la vida. Y cuando lo único que
sabes hacer tiene que ver con temas militares,
pues blanco y en botella. Convertirse en todo
un soldado de fortuna se convirtió en una
opción lógica.)
Y eso no es todo. El fin de la URSS y la caída
de sus estructuras también provocó un importante
descontrol en la gestión de los arsenales,
especialmente en los que quedaron fuera de
la actual Rusia.
De esta forma, por ejemplo,muchos helicópteros
Mi-17 y Mi-24 fueron abandonados y quedaron
en manos de oficiales y pilotos ex-soviéticos
que optaron por darles una salida lucrativa
y sacar tajada.
Y así, de esta manera es cómo los rusos
se familiarizaron con la industria internacional
de las empresas militares hasta el punto de
convertirse, poco a poco, en toda una superpotencia
en el campo.
Ahora bien, si vamos al terreno práctico,
¿Por qué recurrir a este tipo de empresas
y no emplear al ejército convencional? ¿Para
qué se usan realmente este tipo de compañías?
Queridos amigos, amigas, esta es una pregunta
fundamental.
(En el caso de las empresas norteamericanas
la respuesta más aceptada es la eficiencia.
En algunos aspectos, estas empresas logran
reducir sustancialmente los costes de operación
de los ejércitos nacionales gracias a su
especialización en materias muy concretas.
Por ejemplo, hay empresas especializadas en
la protección de aeródromos militares, otras
en la seguridad de perímetros en zonas acotadas
de guerra, otras en el control de checkpoints…
En algunos casos, incluso, prestan servicios
que muchos ejércitos por sí mismos no están
preparados para realizar. Es algo que vimos
por ejemplo en Afganistán. La retirada de
estas empresas privadas hizo que la fuerza
aérea afgano se volviera prácticamente inoperativa.)
Sin embargo, en el caso de las empresas rusas,
junto a estas, encontramos también muchas
más razones.
Por ejemplo, fijaos.
Sí, ya sé que hemos hablado muchas veces
de los hombrecillos verdes de Ucrania, y durante
la invasión del este de Ucrania y Crimea
muchos medios de comunicación dijeron que
se eran soldados rusos.
Y… Bueno, lo cierto es que sí y no al mismo
tiempo. Soldados rusos hubo en el terreno,
casi seguro, y desde luego todos estaban al
servicio del Kremlin. Pero lo más probable
es que muchas de esas unidades que asaltaron
el este de Ucrania formaran parte de empresas
de servicios militares contratadas por el
propio gobierno ruso o por entornos cercanos
a este.
Lo que quiere decir que, sí, que es posible
que Vladimir Putín no mienta - no al menos
técnicamente - cuando dice que el ejército
ruso no invadió Ucrania. Lo que, como veis,
no quiere decir que Rusia no invadiera Ucrania.
Cuestión de matices.
De esta forma las intenciones y el resultado
pueden ser los mismos aunque nadie puede estar
seguro al 100% de la autoría. Nos tenemos
que conformar con un 99%.
(Rusia acumula un amplio bagaje en el uso
tanto de empresas militares privadas como
también de mercenarios en su historial de
conflictos militares.
El más sonado, por ejemplo, es el Batallón
Vostok, formado por el señor de la guerra
checheno Sulim Yamadayev en 1999, al comienzo
de la segunda guerra chechena.
Más tarde, este batallón participaría también
en la guerra de Georgia, entre 2007 y 2008,
y más recientemente en Ucrania, donde ha
sido rebautizado en algunos casos como Batallón
Donbass.)
La cuestión es que los métodos utilizados
por este batallón son tan brutales que ni
siquiera Rusia acepta abiertamente su relación
con ellos. El gobierno ruso se conforma con
decir que se trata simplemente de voluntarios
locales que se suman a su causa.
[Ya sabéis, el altruismo llevado a su quinta
esencia. Todo por la madre patria Rusia…
Lo que en realidad quiere decir: todo por
los billetes del Tio Sam.]
El caso es que supuestamente este batallón
que hemos tomado como ejemplo se disolvió
en 2009… Pero lo cierto es que nunca lo
hizo. Y cuando el 2014 y la crisis de Ucrania,
¿Qué mejor estrategia que recurrir a estos
mismos efectivos?
Claro que no podía ser tan obvio. Había
que mejorar “la subcontrata”
(El gobierno ruso evitó que en el batallón
hubiera demasiadas unidades ligadas a los
conflictos de Chechenia y Georgia. De esta
forma, mientras que el corazón de la conocida
como Unidad del Donbass estaba formado por
mercenarios chechenos experimentados, el grueso
del cuerpo lo integraban combatientes separatistas
de Donetsk que habían sido reclutados con
anterioridad.
Y Por supuesto no se trató únicamente de
las unidades de combate. Con los suministros,
las armas y otras operaciones especializadas,
la operativa fue muy similar.)
Y sí, así es como Rusia subcontrató la
guerra a grupos de mercenarios y empresas
privadas militares.
Pero, amigos, amigas, aquí no termina todo.
La pregunta que podemos hacernos es, ¿Pero
que ocurre con todos estos grupos cuándo
no están trabajando para el gobierno ruso?
¿Qué está pasando hoy por hoy con esta
industria? ¿Quiénes son sus principales
actores?
Pues bien, atentos.
M(RUSIA, ¿UN MACRO HUB DE GUERRA PRIVADA?)
Empecemos con una pregunta: ¿Cuántas empresas
militares privadas creéis que hay en Rusia?
1, 2, 3… ¿Quizás 5?
Pues se calcula que en total hablamos de entre
10 y 20 empresas de este tipo registradas.
Registradas, eso sí, de formas muy variopintas
porque legales, legales, como tal no lo son.
Aunque el propio gobierno sea un buen cliente.
En cualquier caso la mayoría de ellas están
registradas como empresas de seguridad convencional,
claro que de convencional tienen muy poco.
Y como es lógico y siempre ocurre unas destacan
más que otras y muchas están especializadas
en campos muy determinadas.
(Por ejemplo tenemos a Antiterror-Orel, una
empresa militar privada registrada como un
“centro de educación y formación no gubernamental”.
En realidad, la actividad de la empresa es
completamente diferente.
Por ejemplo, Antiterror-Orel se encarga de
proteger por cualquier medio y a gran escala
las operaciones de varias grandes empresas
rusas en países como Irak.
Otro ejemplo bastante conocido es Moran Secutiry,
una empresa militar establecida por antiguos
miembros de la FSB -los servicios secretos
rusos-, y de la Armada nacional.)
Esta empresa, Moran Security, por ejemplo,
afirma en su web que se dedica a escoltar
barcos y a recuperar barcos secuestrados.
Una de sus operaciones más conocidas fue
el rescate de un barco de Emiratos Árabes
Unidos secuestrado en 1999 por sudaneses.
Pero eso no es todo. También tienen un importante
historial de operaciones terrestres, entre
ellas operaciones en zonas como Irak y varios
países de África.
Y por si os lo estabais preguntando, sí,
la empresa cuenta con sus propios buques de
asalto, los cuales tienen matrícula de las
Islas Cook, y sus propios vehículos blindados
. Y en cierta forma cualquier cosa que necesiten
para llevar a cabo sus operaciones.
Porque evidentemente el gobierno ruso no es
ni de lejos su único cliente. El peso de
este tipo de empresas en muchos de los conflictos
internacionales más importantes no es precisamente
pequeño.
Pero, volviendo a Ucrania y a la presencia
de empresas militares privadas en la contienda,
quedaos con este nombre: RSB-Group.
Esta es otra empresa militar privada registrada
en 2011 también por exfuncionarios del FSB
ruso y del Departamento Central de Inteligencia,
más conocido por GRU.
(Esta empresa, además de llevar a cabo numerosas
operaciones de protección de buques en aguas
africanas de Somalia y el Golfo de Guinea
u operaciones de eliminación de minas en
Libia, también parece estar vinculada con
la invasión a Ucrania.
El sitio web ucraniano Infonapalm afirma que
RSB-Group colaboró con los rebeldes respaldados
por Rusia en el Donbass, y que asimismo esta
empresa participó en las operaciones de anexión
de Crimea.)
Para Staver y Skomorokhov, dos observadores
rusos del sector, RSB-Group es la empresa
militar privada más compleja y quizás más
similar a las que podemos encontrar en Occidente
y, en especial, en Estados Unidos.
Por ejemplo, cuentan también con su propio
departamento de ciberdefensa e incluso se
dice que llegaron a rechazar un encargo de
un Estado para influir en las elecciones de
un Estado extranjero. Cliente que, según
ellos, no era Rusia.
El caso, para que veáis hasta dónde llega
la influencia de estas empresas, en los últimos
12 años han sido por lo menos 4 los intentos
de realizar cambios legislativos para legalizarlas
plenamente. Algo con lo que el propio Vladimir
Putin se ha mostrado de acuerdo.
El problema es que legalizarlas supondría
en cierta forma regularizarlas y ponerlas
bajo un estricto control del FSB, el GRU o
el propio Ministerio de Defensa o Exteriores.
Asi que ni ellas mismas están de acuerdo.
Su estatus actual de alegalidad parece el
más conveniente… Para todas las partes,
incluido por supuesto el gobierno ruso.
Por ejemplo, ¿habéis oído hablar de la
guerra híbrida? Pues pensadlo bien, ¿qué
mejor forma de llevarla a cabo que recurrir
a este tipo de compañías?
Ahora bien, la pregunta es: ¿Qué te parece
que tu país recurra a este tipo de empresas?
¿Te parecería bien subcontratar una parte
de la seguridad nacional o de las operaciones
militares en el extranjero?
Déjanos tu respuesta por aquí debajo, en
los comentarios. Y recuerda, si te ha gustado
este vídeo dale a like y suscríbete a nuestro
canal. Y si te gusta lo que hacemos súmate
a nuestra comunidad en Patreon, toda aportación
al proyecto es más que bienvenida.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí. Un saludo
y hasta la próxima.